e
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Monday I hope
everyone had an amazing weekend this is
an exciting day here it's a Monday it's
raining but we're not letting it get us
down no you guys today is such an
exciting day obviously at the morning
toast it's always an exciting day and we
find some reason to get excited to feel
happy to be alive but this morning the
first shipments of a vaccine went out
out of Michigan there's a video that was
on Tik Tok that just got me in my
feelings like all these trucks leaving
the facility the fiser facility like
shipping out all the vaccines so that
the healthcare workers can get them and
it's all these different trucking
companies like UPS FedEx and then the
other trucking companies the other ones
DHL it was just like so heartwarming
it's been such a difficult year and just
like to see that the end is near like I
can't explain the feeling so uh the
video just got me in my feels and I'm
just feeling grateful and excited and
optimistic Glory Be The God yeah I mean
I'm not going to get the vaccine till
like April right no it's it it's I'm not
excited for me it's all on the horizon
for us I'm excited for everyone who's
been putting their life down the line
this entire time that will be getting
getting a vaccine this week like they
have times and dates no it's so crazy
and I'm so excited just like I think
like now safely we can start just like
thinking about life returning to normal
yeah and like maybe going to a concert
next year like at first it was so un
certain because like you really didn't
know when the vaccine would be like in
people's arms but now it's like they're
going to be in people's arms this week
and for the next like six to N9 months
and I just think we can now start seeing
a world Beyond covid we're not there yet
but we we can now safely cautiously
start thinking about it and envisioning
it and that is [__] exciting and
that's just the sort of news and
optimism we needed to end this year and
that's why 2020 is just going to be
different because there is hope is in
the air 100% And we were saying before
like you know 2021 21 you know I don't
want to get everyone's hopes up because
it's yes technically a different year
but things could be just as shitty but
now I'm feeling a like I feel like when
the clock strikes midnight on December
31st like we are going to be a different
planet yes but I also think that yes and
no there's the optimism in the air but
like for a city like New York like now
indoor dining is closed like restaurants
are going out of business ones that had
survived up until this point so like it
is still sad but we have a vision on the
on the horizon hope is all you need and
I have hope today yeah no it's it's a
good day even though it's like so rainy
and by the way when it rains in our
studio like it looks like it's 8:00 p.m.
but we're recording at the same time as
always so just know that it's 10:30 in
the morning yeah well I'm feeling really
annoying today yeah like nice and sing
songy but also like not singing any good
songs okay Jackie your negativity is not
going to get in my way my way my
way I want you to sing some good ass
song
that's what I'm
doing
yeah um no I'm just I got a lot of sleep
over the weekend and I didn't really
like I've been drinking so much like
every weekend consistently that Monday
morning I'm like oh I have Corona like I
just don't feel good because I like
didn't really relax on my weekend and I
actually just like had a really balanced
weekend and I got a lot of sleep and I
spent a lot of time with Theo and like
it was just I'm feeling like I should do
this more often yeah except that we did
like heavily drink on Saturday yeah but
see like but it was was day drinking
which is the key also for just like you
know a vet like me that like wasn't so
crazy except I did throw up at dinner
but I don't think it anything to do with
the alcohol I think it was poisoned no
but like because you drink during the
day like the Sunday doesn't suffer as
much and it was really nice I had a nice
balance weekend too because I drank we
had a good time but I also read an
amazing book that I started on Friday
that I finished yesterday called
luckiest girl alive Dana was telling me
about it and it just I didn't know
anything about it when I read it and I
absolutely loved it and Jackie just
chatted it up so much on her Instagram
when we were out together on Saturday
just like tuck tuck talking about the
book that I was so heavily influenced
actually purchased the book so she's
going to read it soon vac so exciting
yeah um and speaking of vacation this is
our last week of shows for the year and
we're going to miss you guys but we're
going to be having a good ass time yeah
no I am going to miss you for sure but I
will also definitely be having a good
ass time g a gat but last week of shows
so enjoy them I mean last week I feel
like should have been the final week of
shows because they were just five out of
five premium ass shows like five stars
all around every episode more funnier
than the next and that would have been a
great way to go out but I guess we'll
just have to keep that energy up for
this week yeah we're just going to have
to bring it it's already been broughten
that was like such a lame part of Bring
It On like it's not from Bring It On yes
it is no so it's actually so she says
bring it obviously they never respond
it's already been brought in that's from
Not Another Teen Movie yeah but no the
whole concept of like bring it like what
is it you know yeah it's the energy like
I get it but it just it's like kind of
cringey like you better bring it br oh
we will it's like you both know what the
other is talking about it's so vague no
you it it everything of the sort
everything of the sort yeah um so it's
been now um four days since we've gotten
the ever More album and I'm still I'm
I'm taking my time I'm not 100% there in
terms of like having lived with it but I
did spend a significant amount of my
weekend listening to it and studying it
and just living with it and it's such a
beautiful album and honestly some of the
songs have just like really really
evolved into like totally different
pieces of music I think Willow which for
Taylor I would say probably in all of
her albums the songs that she releases
as her lead singles are almost always my
least favorite like almost always I
don't know what it is but so that's why
I didn't really have like a ton of Hope
for Willow I kind of just like was like
oh it's like a fine song but I'll like
skip past it but my God it's so good
like it's it's just so unlike her to put
like one of her best songs as her single
so I wasn't expecting it and I kind of
like wrote it off almost but that's what
I get for just judging before I know
anything it's just such a beautiful
album and I'm I'm really happy with it
oh good and there's a song on there
about Theo which is really was really
cool that was my next question like
what's Theo's favorite song is it the
one about him yeah that was pretty cool
of Taylor to just like acknowledge Him
like a nod you know artist to artist um
a lot of celebrities have been
acknowledging Theo these days Pete
Davidson Pete Davidson and
um ice cream chilling black pink oh yeah
do do do yeah but um when Taylor sings
Hey Doro it's just it warms my heart
because it's like she sees his Beauty
and his grace and just to clarify for
those who might have been confused on
our Instagram page that was not actually
Theo the cavaliere in the picture with
Pete Davidson outside of SNL but holy
[__] did it look like him I just want to
say like there's no proof that it wasn't
Theo that's true cuz I was out you were
out who knows what he got into Ben was
out as well but I just know that he
doesn't have that sweater but maybe he
picked it up on the way maybe it's a new
sweater
maybe it wasn't him I like I'm not
convinced I like know what Theo looks
like a te so like of course it looked a
lot like him but I knew it wasn't him
but to the average viewer who like sees
Theo on Instagram or on the show like it
looks like him so agree I didn't expect
so many people to think and then I dug
myself into like this grave where
everyone was like is it him I can't tell
and I was like I thought we all knew
like this was a joke I mean but still
like it's unclear it could be him
because no one was with him no one knew
what he got into on Saturday night right
like remember that movie with Cynthia
Nixon Baby's Day Out where like the baby
goes to the museum in the gym yeah I
think Theo takes himself out he is a fan
of com obviously his mom and SNL's the
only show in town right now so he went
on down there and he met his friend Pete
I don't think it's so farfetched me
neither and if you don't know what we're
talking about look at our Instagram for
the picture educate yourselves today we
have a fabulous show of course the Fast
Five lots to discuss because we had real
house was of PTO reunion part one which
was such unbelievable television thank
you for entertaining me like it was so
good I thank you Monique Samuel I did
not pick my phone up once like I was
just in so intrigued and then we also
had real house of Atlanta so we have a
lot to discuss you we have a lot to
discuss so I think we should just jump
right into the fast five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning
toast sure sure sure sure sure but we
can't we can't take a bite out of her
morning toast yet why cuz I forgot to
tell you something H today's episode is
brought to you by better help is there
something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals well better help
will assess your needs and match you
with your own licensed professional
therapists where you can start
communicating in under 48 hours better
help is not a crisis line it's not
self-help it's professional counseling
and it's all done securely online
there's a broad range of expertises
available which may not be locally
available to you in many areas but their
servic is available for clients
worldwide you can log into your account
anytime and send a message to your
counselor where you'll get timely and
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule weekly or video phone sessions
so you won't have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room as with
traditional therapy betterhelp is
committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they make it easy
and free to change counselors if needed
it's more affordable than traditional
offline counseling and financial aid is
available better help wants you start
living a happier life today you can
visit their website and read their
testimonials of all the people who love
betterhelp and if you want to visit
betterhelp.com toast that's better
hp.com toast you can join the over a
million people who have taken charge of
their mental health with with the help
of an experienced professional in fact
so many people have been using better
help that they are recruiting additional
counselors in all 50 states um so the
morning toast offer is 10% off for your
first month but you have to use the link
betterhelp.com toast again that link
will get you 10% off your first month
it's never been a better time crazy
times the holidays can be hard for
people if you've been wanting to start
therapy you've been nervous about it or
you actually haven't been able to leave
your house because of Co betterhelp is
the perfect thing betterhelp.com toast
for 10% off your first month yes okay
first story some big news of the weekend
I just want to issue a trigger warning
beforehand because we're going to talk
about an abusive relationship oh yes I
heard about this FKA twigs is suing shy
abuff over an alleged abusive
relationship she has accused him of
sexual battery assault and infliction of
emotional distress the New York Times
has reported I didn't even know that
they dated I know one incident described
in the lawsuit occurred just after
Valentine's Day in 2019 and she claims
that Shia was driving recklessly
threatening to threatening to crash the
car if she didn't profess her love for
him as the passenger in the car she
claimed she begged to be let out of the
car and he pulled over at a gas station
followed her out of the car and
assaulted her throwing her against the
car according to the lawsuit so there's
a number of incidents that she cites but
also now CA is coming out and calling
shy lauff a pathological liar C is
saying that Shia conned her into an
adulterous relationship she's warning
women to stay away from the very sick
star and Shila Buff did respond to the
lawsuit from from FK twigs and was like
yes this is all true like and I'm very
sick wow so it's first of all I didn't
even know that any of these people like
were linked I didn't know shy buff dated
FK Twigs I didn't know shy buff had a
relationship with CIA and then I didn't
know that FK Twigs is now dating Matt
Healey from The 1975 cuz he like
released a statement supporting her so
I'm just like learning so much learning
so much but um in regards to this story
I feel like it's super I just love like
ca and FKA like coming together coming
together and supporting one another and
just like speaking out when it's like
like so hard so hard and I'm sure FKA
twigs like you know speaking out it's so
brave to do and then to have someone in
the industry like come and coroporate
you like I'm sure means so much 100% so
I just I hope that Justice is served and
I'm just really proud of them for
speaking up against like and he's a
major player in
Industry hard I think everyone has known
for a long time that he's definitely
unwell in a lot of ways and I think we
all just like watch it and he like
becomes a meme but it's like not funny
and this is like proof that it's not
yeah for sure I hope there's you know I
didn't like I didn't know you could like
sue someone yeah no I wasn't but then I
guess it's but then I think of like
Amber herd and Johnny Deb but they're
like fighting over like divorce in Lial
right so I just didn't know that you
could sue someone like yeah in a
relationship I didn't really know that
either but I guess it totally makes
sense like you can CU it's illegal yeah
so we'll see how the suit plays out but
I just think I think a lot of this was
to draw raise awareness and then first
it was like warning other women to stay
away from him and I think that's
important for women to know yeah me too
this is a terrible story but terrible
hopefully the road to justice is on its
way okay another really sad story um
Charlie Pride country music icon Legend
has passed away from a CO Charlie Pride
Char country music icon Legend an
incredible pom pom the pride of country
music lit has passed away after a covid
related death now raising questions
about whether or not he might have
contracted Co at the CMA Awards which
were last month and he was honored with
the Lifetime Achievement Award there the
CMA Awards have put out a statement
saying quote everyone affiliated with
the CMA Awards followed strict testing
protocols outlined by the City Health
Department and unions Charlie was tested
prior to traveling to Nashville he was
tested upon Landing in Nashville and
again on show day with all tests coming
back negative after returning to Texas
following the CM May Awards Charlie
again tested negative multiple times all
of us in the country music Community are
heartbroken by Charlie's passing out of
respect for his family during their
grieving period we'll be not commenting
on this further right so no one has
actually confirmed whether or not um the
CMAs were the place where he got covid
um I think a lot of people including
Marin mors who tweeted about it were
just like assuming almost because of the
timing yeah Marin marus tweeted and
deleted but she said I don't want to
jump to conclusions because no family
statement has been made but if this was
a result of the CM being indoors we
should all be outraged rest in power
Charlie so I just want to say if this
was a result of the C being indoors and
just the CMAs in general I actually do
think that people could have thought
twice about inviting in person I didn't
even think about it at the time cuz it
really seemed like so well done and if
that was the case that he had gotten it
there actually now that I think about it
like the Lifetime Achievement Award like
could have been received remotely and
like the rest of the thing could have
gone on without him um but at the same
time I don't think it's fair to assume
that's where he got it even though the
timeline like does it could it could
make sense um I just don't think it's
fair to like jump to any conclusions yet
and what's a covid related injury or a
CO related death would be so covid um
like the disease itself like caused harm
to other parts of his body and then
maybe I don't like it could have been
heart failure right Co initially right
or like because he was older maybe he
had some like pre-existing yeah yeah so
I don't know but I just think the way we
you know address it both publicly and
just like how like we should just be
careful
because there's aside from the timing
there's no proof that he had received it
there no just speculation but at the
same time I didn't think it at the time
but now that I'm thinking about it like
I do feel like the CMAs were really well
done and that's because most people in
CMAs are like young and healthy that
like the one person who was older and
receiving his like maybe could have
received it remotely yeah now that I
think about it yeah I'm sure that people
will continue to try and figure it out
and also if if it was a a a super
spreader event then other people would
have in the country music world would
have gotten Co too that's true I feel
like maybe we so I do feel like there
are waste that we'll find out yeah but I
also definitely feel like celebrities in
general um like aren't telling people
when they get covid cuz like we knew
Khloe Kardashian had covid from Keeping
Up with the Kardashians but she had it
like a year ago or whenever yeah in
March you know what I mean so I feel
like not everyone is forthcoming no I
don't know I feel like every day I'm
seeing a story or it's like so and so
was telling us now that they had Co like
4 months ago and yeah I agree they're
they're definitely being strange about
it so if there if it was some type of
super spitter event like we might not
know but those things really don't stay
quiet no they don't they don't um okay
next up some Taylor Swift news like some
Taylor Swift speculation that I really
want to talk about because I just think
it's like so obvious but I don't know
okay Taylor Swift might release a
surprise third album called wood Veil so
the signs of the D Swifty code are
pointing to a third album because she
said the story continues there's
woodveil written in the artwork for
folklore and they think that these are
triplets not just twins no it's very
possible there are certain like Taylor
Swift theories that like I get really
invested in um and sometimes they come
to fruition sometimes they don't this
third album like okay I see the points
everyone is making I hope it's true but
I'm not like you know tying up my ship
and getting on board you know what I
mean no I'm just I'm sitting around like
waiting for it sure and if that happens
wonderful but I'm so I don't want to be
greedy like I'm so grateful for the
imagine you just put out like a second
amazing work of art in one year like
record smashing chart topping and then
everyone's just like well where's the
third yeah so I'm so grateful and I
don't want to be greedy like the two
albums that we have are more than enough
for me and if this is where the folklore
era ends it will have been not just good
but great you know I mean beyond beyond
so over and above it would have been
enough di if we get the third album okay
I will be very appreciative but I'm not
expecting anything I I Taylor Swift is
very unpredictable and every time we
think we figured it out we usually don't
so I just I the three Cardigans the
three stars I'm just feeling like like
to me I always see these theories that
um the swifties put out and I'm like
okay this is farfetched but I saw this
one I was like yeah no for sure this is
it sometimes that happens but then it's
like enough time goes by where nothing
happens that you just forget about it
and like the theory goes unanswered yeah
that's true that's the life of a Swifty
it's like I don't know I I can't get so
excited anymore so many of my theories
are untrue like and just never come to
life yeah like I really thought her and
Joe were definitely married and maybe
even had a baby after peace came out but
give you my while give you a child
that's true but there's no nothing to
say that they're not married that's true
but I also just don't think Taylor Swift
will ever legally be married that's true
that is financially I just don't don't
think it makes sense that's very true
yeah I you our next story is some more
sad news this is just an snd a sad news
day Lisa Vander pump is is devastated
over the death of her beloved dog Jiggy
and so is the Bravo Community cuz this
is wild Theo cover your ears the Vander
pump R star announced the news on social
media Saturday saying she and her family
are devastated quote he was truly loved
and we know many of you loved him too he
inspired us to start our rescue and we
will always be grateful jiggy's Legacy
lives on with every dog Vander pump
rules Vander pump dog saves rip Jiggy we
love you you say rip I did that's weird
rip do you say rip like not really I
never it's like so disrespectful like
rip I don't give a rip like rest in
peace is I'm Sor it just said rip like
it's okay RP and if it's like all
lowercase it's just like rip you know
rip rip rip I don't give a rip I'm
actually really excited for the real
house of Dallas but I digress back to
Jiggy Jiggy is like the first lady
dogwise of Bravo and there's been so
many he's the first dog the first dog
thank you
um first lady dogwise like I don't know
what that meant to say but yes first dog
and this is just like crazy and I feel
like a lot of people like we've just
been like this is going to sound
terrible but like jg's just been so old
for so long that I feel like I've just
been like waiting for this announcement
um and it never came so I'm like maybe
he like drank from the Tuck Everlasting
Fountain and he's going to live forever
yeah no and now that like it's here it's
like wow he lived such a long life and
and he was sick like for a long time um
yes he had a lot of complications but he
lived a very good life and it's it's
just really sad cuz he's an icon and a
meaningful life but his legacy is so
meaningful yeah and even though like I
truly like in my soul despise Lisa
Vanner pump I actually like I think the
work that she does with Vanner pump dogs
and just like her love for dogs in the
uland Dog Festival is so admirable I
just have something to say I'm like done
despising Lisa wait that's like so crazy
that you said that because like earlier
and I just don't want to like discredit
all the work I've done over the last 10
years like into the gospel anti Lisa
vaner pump but watching this most recent
season with Le sa vaner prob and like
seeing Kyle just be like really kind of
weird and shady I was like hm no it's
like Kyle's Bobby Bobby Fisher maybe
heavy is the head that wears the crown
and her neck was hurting no it's not
even about the women It's like because
I've forgotten all the reasons why I
dislike her and all the injustices I'm
like she's a nice lady well yeah that's
what happens like out of sight out of
mind I feel fondly but I don't even like
her on Vander pump rules which is like
where we see her more recently yeah no I
and but it's been a while since Vander
pump r
like the whole thing I think I'm still
going to stick to like spreading the
gospel of the Lisa Vanner pump hatred
but I do agree part of me is like I'm
just part me as like who cares I don't
feel as fervent about it I completely
agree but I still just just because I
spent so much of my young adulthood like
preaching to my friends why like Lisa
Vander pump was like really like the
most menacing potster I just don't think
I can go back on my word I know and also
you know what I feel you know what I
think endear us to her now her to us
she's a podcaster a podcaster and like
there's just we have a warm spot in our
heart for fellow podcasters that's fair
honestly you know yeah so plus she's
think she's having a tough week somebody
to think about yeah okay our fifth and
final story we just Breeze through these
because all we want to do is talk about
finder um is such an interesting Sports
celebrity news story okay also can I
just interject with like one story that
I read that I thought was really
interesting and I meant to send to you
sure so the um the founder of Cameo that
app went on a podcast was just talking
about like the success of Cameo and how
like celebrities are making real money
and he said that this year the number
one earner I want you to guess who made
over a million dollar in in his own
sales like after commissions um from
Cameo oh [__] yeah I would have said a
real housewife it's so
shocking number uh Spencer Pratt nope is
he even on Cameo I don't know but like
it's not even in that realm not reality
TV no
um someone in the Sports World then no I
don't know what made me think of it okay
I don't know Kevin from the office Brian
balm Gardner I mean like I would never
even know does that actually make a lot
of sense like when you think about it
yeah and on the podcast the founder was
like he takes like so much pride in his
cameos like he like makes them real
works of art and he doesn't just like
you know put a 10-second video together
and I thought that was really
interesting that is really an
interesting factoid yeah Brian bam
Gardner made a million dollars on Cameo
this year congratulations good for you
okay our fifth and final story of little
Sports celebrity news Cody Sim
says he qualified for the Olympic
swimming trials he's going to the
Olympics on behalf of Australia oral of
Australia damn on Saturday he said that
he had qualified for his first Olympic
trials sorry trials yeah he's not going
to the Olympics going the olymp to the
place he's going to the Olympics trials
yeah Olympic trials he said I'd love to
share this personal Milestone and let
you in on my current Journey as an
athlete that I've kept relatively lowkey
until now um he said he he posted this
on Instagram he said I've had the chance
to experience and learn so much as a
musician and touring around the world
releasing albums performing as a leading
man on Broadway publishing a work of
poetry oh my God humble brag yeah like
this is a little obnoxious yeah um and
now he's qualifying for the Olympics in
2021 wow I mean I do wish he was for
America so that sexy washboard AB could
be like an American hero but I do
understand that he's Australian and
that's not how these things work um
happy for him I mean this does seem like
I don't know if you could just like wake
up and decide to be an Olympics swimmer
I think these are things like you do
since like you're not I don't know ask
Michael Phelps um but I appreciate his
uh passion yeah he said for years he'd
been fueled by the silent fire in my
stomach of returning to my first love
the sport of swimming with the idea that
he's also promoting his poetry book
while he writ right of course available
on Amazon speaking of with the idea that
2020 promoting a book make sure to order
my book girln job.com book comes out in
just 5 weeks don't miss out pre-order It
audiobook ebook and paper print versions
all available ailable on Amazon and
other retailers girl job.com book sorry
so he he's promoting his poetry book
with the idea that well no inadvertently
just by using poetic language in his
Instagram caption the idea that 2020
would be the year he'd start trying
again after only 5 months back in the
water with his incredible coach I was
able to take out a win and secure a spot
at next year's Australian Olympic trials
that's crazy some people just like you
know those people who just try something
try their hand Talent try this talent
but it's like not really like that
doesn't really happen the Olympics like
he's just Mak get seem like I woke up
one day and 5 months later I was going
to the Olympics if he actually makes it
to the Olympics I will be incredibly
impressed yes no but like for a he won
the Mas singer like he is a very
talented celebrity right that's true and
for him to also be a super talented
athlete like Olympics competing at an
Olympic level well that means that
you're the best of the best and I just
don't I I I'm not trying to be skep
skeptical I just don't think he can do
it I don't think he can do it I don't
think you just wake up and 5 months
later you like okay maybe if you're
lucky you make it to the trial and
because you just have that like innate
talent but these are it's like a
disgrace to the people who have
literally been like swimming since they
were nine just to get to the Olympics
and like this is their year speed you
know he's not doing anything like
special or different like he's in that
same pool with the same CL so I'm saying
if he really gets makes it to the the
best of the best of the Olympic team I
will apologize okay but I'm saying even
if he doesn't the fact that he who like
is so talented in other Realms even made
it to the Olympic trials like he's a
really good swimmer no he's a good
swimmer for sure he's like a tall man in
shape and yeah but so and so anyone can
just make it to the Olympic trials no
but it's not the Olympics so I'm just
saying like if we get to the Olympics I
will take back what I said but I just
think this is like this is like one of
those things so tough to impress I've
been noticing like celebrities just like
keep doing things in other people's like
the Paul Brothers like now becoming UFC
fighters when it's like no people who
have literally been like waiting their
whole life to fight Floyd Mayweather and
now it's like Logan Paul gets to do it
when he's been fighting it's just like
celebrities and by the way I do it
myself as well like I not I'm like
categorizing myself as like a celebrity
but like you know I just released music
because I feel like it even though I'm
not a singer like it's just like a thing
it's like celebrities just like keep
like doing things and like getting to
like the best of different Industries
just because they're celebrities right
and I agree with you on that point thep
is based on talent but this is just
completely based on Talent has nothing
to do with the fact that he's a
celebrity
no maybe no no I don't how it works in
Australia but I'm just saying if he gets
to the Olympic no
trials I will take back what I said but
for now it's just like Cody
Simpson sit down no but like he's still
remarkably skilled and nothing about
being a celebrity like got him that time
in that pool I don't know it got him
like the like whatever no I hear what
you're saying like but they also him
being a celebrity like he got a fancy
coach like you know what I mean he put
in the work but but like I don't know I
just I don't really feel like I can
really make a statement yet until I know
if he made the team okay but I just want
to say this becomes a trend of like
celebrities becoming Olympians becoming
Olympic athlet I'm here for it now that
break dancing is an Olympic sport well
you know what's interesting about
celebrities becoming Olympic athletes
It's like because um Olympic athletes
are also celebrities that and basketball
is a winter or right summer summer
Olympic sport and like the best of um
American NBA players usually play for
the American Olympic team and actually
sometimes foreign NBA players like play
play for their home countries and it's
like weird to be playing your teammates
but that's also weird because those are
celebrities like LeBron James is a
celebrity like and him being an Olympian
it's like he's honestly too famous for
the Olympics no like it was crazy I
remember when they all went to the last
Olympics and I remember when like Chloe
and Lamar were together I think Lamar
went to the Olympics while they were
together and it is crazy to see your
favorite celebrities in the Olympics and
that's what I'm saying 100% I'm just
saying I'm not
convinced that's all well you know what
we'll keep you posted we I need to find
out when the Australian Olympic Swim
trials are because you know what we'll
know if he made it but we won't know if
he didn't no 100% if you never hear from
us again he didn't make
it in regards to this story um you know
what but Cody I just want I just want to
let you know like I'm I'm rooting for
you no I'm rooting for America no but
like I would love to see Cody Simpson at
the Olympics that would just like give
us a level of Olympics coverage
celebrity Olympics coverage that we need
can I tell you how much I love the
Olympics I know we were jip this year
yeah I I really sorry that's not a word
I should be using anymore I just learned
by the way I also just learned that too
it's um it's offensive to Gypsy I'm
sorry we were I feel like a lot of
people don't know that yeah no I didn't
know it until recently me too um what I
was going to say about the Olympics is
like I never feel more like redneck I
love America than I do when the Olympics
are on I'm like you know like running
around with my shirt off like with like
American flag painted on my belly like I
just it's the best time of year like
some people love the holiday season in
922 but I love especially Summer Olympic
season yeah I totally agree and we
didn't get Olympics this year which is
too justce for the winter no winter's
winter is like a really close second but
nothing beats summer and like Michael
Phelps in the swimming no in the
gymnastics gymnastics but honestly I
really actually enjoy like all those
weird skiing Sports yeah very cool yeah
um okay let's dive into our TV recap
because the ra house is bomic just like
made my year yesterday and our Real
Housewives of pomac and Atlanta reunions
and Atlanta episodes are brought to you
by stamps.com this holiday season more
people will be mailing stuff than ever
before that means the post office is
going to be busy you don't have time for
that stamps.com brings the post office
and now UPS shipping right to your
computer mail and ship anything for the
conveni from the convenience of your
home or office because with stamps.com
you can do anything at the post office
you can do anything that you can do at
the post office with just a few clicks
they save you money with deep discounts
that you can't even get at the post
office they bring the services of the
USPS and UPS right to your computer simp
use any computer to print official US
postage 24/7 for any letter any package
any class of mail anywhere you want to
send once your mail is ready just
schedule a pickup or drop it off it's
that simple plus like we said you get
amazing discounts with stamps.com you
get 5 cents off of every first class
stamp and up to 40% off priority mail
and up to 62% off UPS shipping rates
it's a fraction of the cost of expensive
postage meters don't spend a minute of
your holiday season at the post office
this year sign up for stamps.com instead
there's no risk and with our promo code
toast you get a special offer that
includes a 4-we trial plus free postage
and a digital scale no long-term
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in
toast that's stamps.com code toast
stamps.com never go to the post office
again it real housewives of pic run real
housewi The Hope reunion was on last
night the women really looked fabulous
you know collectively they looked really
good and then when you zoomed in a
little bit more everyone's outfit was
like a little focked like Wendy's dress
like kept falling over on like her her
right like breast uh like thing was just
like falling over I didn't notice
Robin's hair until her zoom in thing and
it was very confusing Ashley love you
the inside of your cape was just
absolutely awful best dressed is Queen
Mo'Nique and queen uh Karen Huger yes
and you know I have to give her credit
Candace did look pretty cute Candace
actually always looks very good yeah uh
yeah I didn't think like the looks I I
thought again I feel like if you look at
all the poic reunions like it's just not
great but I feel like this one and I
don't like that they all wore the same
color I think that's like such a weird
like I like the idea of it but then in
practice it's like I don't know I feel
like they could have worn the same Hue
or like same family of colors yeah it is
like they were like bridesmaides whereas
I feel like sometimes you know I feel
like in New Jersey they all wear
Sparkles but there's silver there's gold
there's rose gold there's a million
different things to allar we like this
shade of yellow I thought was strange I
actually liked it because first of all I
think when they took the photos and like
it they all just looked like this like
unit but then what I really liked is
like because they're really all given
like the same exact guidelines we really
get to see like who doesn't know how to
dress and who knows how to dress and the
fact that we spent almost half the
reunion last night like diving in on
gizelle's awful style in in terms of
fashion and awful home decor style led
by Karen Huger like and the viewers and
the viewers are really are vocal about
it like nothing gives me more joy than
like five what is it six seasons now
like we've just been like skirting
around this issue and now and now we
said it and now we said it and really
like Karen was being so funny and
Jazelle like really didn't have a
defense and it and it is so weird and I
think what Wendy said she's definitely
on to something that Jazelle is like too
pretty pretty she's pretty girl syndrome
she doesn't like she's never had to like
work that hard in those other areas
because like she's so stunning she could
wear whatever she wants yeah I I
personally relate to that I mean because
I've just been like so beautiful my
whole whole life like people you just
used to treat me so differently they
still do um I relate to that like I
really don't have to try because I'm so
stunning no but Karen was just so on
point with all her come and I thought
that obviously the end of the episode
Jazelle had nothing to say for herself
but I even thought in the beginning when
Karen and Jazelle were doing their thing
of just like insulting each other and
just doing that I thought Karen was so
on point and Jazelle like really had
nothing to say so she was just like
saying the same thing over and over just
like sort of mocking Karen but like
wasn't actually contributing like didn't
have any like insults in her back pocket
except for like the Geral comment but
then like Karen turned it on her I'm
assuming it's an old age medication this
is why Karen Huger is the absolute Queen
because she said that's AIS and she
mispronounced Aegis and so Wendy
corrected her and Wendy was definitely
being condescending when she corrected
her but instead of like fighting with
Wendy she said what was it Wendy a gist
thank you honey like it was just so
smart like she didn't get sidetracked
she's an amazing fighter like you know
what I mean and last night's episod
really for me like
showed was like emblematic of how I've
been feeling this whole season where
it's like Karen Huger is like the
absolute Queen gets no no respect and
Jazelle like has questions for everybody
but answers to nobody no and so we need
to just talk about the anation moment of
the night when Monique came with her
binder and it's always like when someone
starts bringing up printed out text
messages like it's it's a joke but she
came prepared because she had this story
of Jamal's girlfriend and if she had
said it with nothing to back it up
people would been like oh Monique you're
being crazy and you're just being
spiteful the look on everyone's faces
everyone knew what she was talking about
this this other female Pastor who is it
I don't know like it's Jamal's real
girlfriend I guess and he's dating with
Jazelle for the show which is just like
such a crazy thing to say but then it
also seems to be very true then Mo'Nique
read out the phone number Jazelle had to
confirm that that's his phone number
that was crazy and then that made
everything else true and at first all
the women were like monque what are you
doing what are you doing but then
Monique was just spitting fact after
fact after fact and everyone shut the
[__] up because everyone knows that it's
most likely true and like now you can't
even deny what Monique is saying and
Jazelle for the first time was just like
speechless and I hate to see a woman
taken down and like a a person's
relationship like put into question but
after all Jazelle has done over the
years like questioning everyone's
marriage baby like she's just so she's
always stirring the pot and like really
putting people in uncomfortable
situations and it's like you can't have
this very confusing relationship sh no
matter what you believe like they he
cheated on her he has the her jelle's
dad said he has children with like six
other women six to seven seven is the
most recent so it's like you can't help
but question it so it's like gazelle
when you are sitting on this like you
should really be quiet about other
people's things just so nobody comes
prying into your business no it's the
Golden Rule don't dish it out if you
can't take it 100% so just to finally
see like Jazelle be like really just put
in her place and it felt so good and I
feel like everyone who's ever been like
interrogated by Jazelle just like was
living like I know Ashley and Karen like
they were just living for it living for
it and I I can't believe Jazelle allowed
herself to react like that like she had
nothing like she couldn't even retort
she had nothing to say like her silence
was confirmation she always has
something to say she always yeah like
she could have just gotten back and
forth and she just like I don't know she
had I that's why that's what I'm saying
even with Karen like she just didn't
have like the the fight in her like I
don't know I also thought that the way
that they're sitting is very strange
because usually it's like side vers side
so it would have been like Wendy Jazelle
Robin and Candace and then the other
three but I feel like because they're so
far apart they actually had to put
people who are fighting like next to
each other because if Wendy is screaming
at Karen they're literally like 30 feet
apart because they're so separate
because of Co yeah so I did think it was
weird that Robin was sitting there I
couldn't when they were zooming in on
people like I couldn't get a sense of
like who's next to who I didn't like
mind it so much but yeah it definitely
they're like taking some learnings from
New York reion where Andy was all the
way there like they tried to do the
circle and I think it's I think it is
going as best as it possibly could um in
regards to the conversation about um
Wendy's degrees I did have a lot to say
because I I kind of like agreed with
Wendy because she's like that's just
like so a part of our culture and like I
hate to blame it on like a cultural
difference but I kind of understood what
she was saying and and I know like in
certain like cultures like your
education is everything so you keeping
up so I kind of understood that but I
wish she addressed Ashley's very well
said claim that it's like it's not about
you bragging it's like you use it to put
others down and like you bring it up
when literally no she's like I feel like
I bring it Wendy said I have to bring it
up because I I need to defend myself
because people are talking about it but
then Ashley's like wait when we were at
Candace's uh when we were at Monique's
Le house like you just brought it up
because like literally nobody said
anything so it's like I wish he just
would have addressed the way that she
uses it to put other people down because
I did appreciate her explaining why she
brings it up so much but that doesn't
help me understand the she doesn't see
it that way you know so I do yeah uh it
was an interesting conversation I'm glad
that she talked about it cuz I feel like
that's when I've been like watching and
then like looking on Twitter that's like
how everyone feels it's funny and it's
funny but it it does make sense if it is
a cultural difference and also like she
should be extremely proud yeah exactly
like I would be did you think that Karen
Huger really like spoke to Robin and
Jazelle on the plane home from Portugal
and said like we need Wendy off the show
I don't think she said it like that and
also from what I've seen on the show I
know that Jazelle is not reliable in a
game of telephone Floy freelancer okay
we need to talk about that right so like
why would I say if gazelle said that
Karen said something I know for a fact
that Jazelle misremembers or misre
repeats or adds things that weren't
there she adds color she paints a little
bit right so given that no I don't
believe I maybe the sentiment of like
Wendy isn't a good cast member or she's
not like a she's not Jing with the group
or like she's not contributing like
maybe she said something to that effect
but not in the way that jezelle said it
and so so I'm going to believe Karen I
agree I feel like literally this whole
because we finally
have on camera like in sequence the Floy
freelancer thing we saw what Karen said
verbatim we saw what Jazelle then
repeated to Wendy we this is like and
she's and when they called her out on
the reunion she's like oh I just added
one word and I'm so grateful Andy was
like no no you added the most important
word cuz otherwise she gets called her a
freelancer she for a living so it's like
I that that whole thing bothered me so
and I remember watching it being like
she didn't call her a Floy freelancer
and it never came to blow but now that
we're sitting down at the reunion like
rewatching footage I was so glad and
that is proof that like literally I
don't think I could ever believe
anything Jazelle ever said yeah if she
says someone said this I know for
certain that they didn't and you know
what Karen has not lied to me and I feel
like she definitely has lied to The
Other Women I didn't invite Monique but
then she comes on her confessional she's
like yeah it she doesn't lie to us yeah
she doesn't lie to us so I if Karen said
she said this and not that I'm going
with Karen and you know what Wendy is
like Wendy Jazelle the four of them
they're so obsessed with just like being
against Mo'Nique that Wendy should
actually be mad at Jazelle for Jazelle
called her a Floy freelancer that means
Jazelle came up with the word Floy that
means in her brain because Karen didn't
say it Jazelle thinks that Wendy is a
Floy freelancer that was not um delved
into enough for me and like that
required an apology to both Karen and
Wendy which I don't think that we got no
but Wendy's just so obsessed with like
being in this crew of four women who
like want to take Monique off the show
that they can't fight in
they're losing sight of the big picture
which is Monique yeah um also you notice
how um Ashley's hair was straight and
then curly no so in the beginning like
the first 10 15 minutes Ashley's Hair
was like blown out straight and then
they when they cut her again she has
like ringlet curls and then again it's
like straight like she changed her like
so it's my understanding that they
couldn't get touchups at all so they did
like a big chunk and then a long break
where they got lunch and hair and makeup
touch-ups and and then the rest so maybe
they cut up a piece from part the end
and put it in the middle yeah I was
thinking that because I was noticing
like a lot of them were shiny and I
noticed that on real houses of New York
too and that's because usually when they
take a break like their hair and makeup
people come to the set and just touch
them up but because of covid they're not
even allowed on set so they only got one
big one and actuallyy changed her
hairstyle which like which is a crazy
thing to do yeah I love Chris Samuel so
much like when they were just like
praying and I just I can't wait for him
to come out oh my God Candice when she
was like Andy was like I heard you moved
out of your house she's like well well
have to wait for Chris to get here to
talk about it so it's like okay I don't
know why you need your husband there to
an but sure but okay obviously there's
something Chris needs to be here for so
we'll wait but then she gave it up and
they bought a house yeah and then um and
then she was like and still thinking
about having a baby like Andy was like
have you made a decision she's like yeah
we're still thinking about it maybe
you'll hear something soon how is no one
going to call her out on like the fact
that she had a fake storyline like we
literally need you know who we need
Megan King edman no um Jennifer Aiden
like she did to Melissa with the sister
the baby you know that's what C is doing
that's so true by the way that's so
funny because there's like brands of
half like Megan King Edmond's brand is
like if there's a mystery to solve like
you're getting Megan can detective
Edmond detective Edmonds but you're
really you're right like if there's a
fake storyline to be called out it's
Miss Jennifer Aiden yeah cuz that's what
Candace is doing and like it's so
transparent but like no one will call
her out on it and honestly I didn't even
think that that was what Melissa Gorga
might have been doing until I'm like oh
totally yeah because like I love Melissa
Gorga but like that season was a little
silly for her the sister the mysterious
sister and
yeah just like such a weird storyline
incredibly weird um so all in all part
one reunions are usually never that good
like it was really and it's like I just
feel like we're gearing up and I'm so
happy for Moni cuz obviously she's been
totally sidelined during the season and
like even in the beginning she didn't
even chime in it's like she's a friend
of like she's not even there and and the
women just have completely written her
off but she's coming back better than
ever and as a Monique stand this is what
I've been waiting for this whole time I
felt like so good I thought Andy's
question about like colorism as it
pertains to like the way some of the
women describe like Mo'Nique and just
like the like the physical Behavior I
thought that was a really interesting
conversation um and one that I feel like
we've been you know thinking about when
discussing this fight and how like terms
like aggressive and um what was the
other word they
said well Mo'Nique had
said no Wendy was saying ferocious thank
you ferocious and aggressive are just
like not words and then and Andy was
like asking like questions that I was
wondering too like what so what are
appropriate words and when he was like
just use a dictionary like I thought
that was a really interesting
conversation and honestly I never even
really knew what colorism was within the
black community until pic because they
used to talk about it a lot yeah they
used to talk about it a lot and I
remember when I was reading um Gabrielle
yun's book it was something that came up
a lot and I learned a lot about it and
so it was interesting to hear them
comment on it and if they feel feel that
it has played a part in the way that the
the women talk about each other and or
the viewers talk about the women also
just really quickly the Wendy Slither is
probably my favorite thing from the
whole season like and honestly it's it's
so funny to watch Karen do it and then
immediately watch Wendy do it because
literally like the same energy same
energy like she literally captured it so
well like I was
crying Karen's just so funny like and
honestly It's upsetting that she gets no
[__] respect no I know it the the the
Wendy Slither was so funny and only
because like Karen did it so well like
the way she imitated it it's perfect
it's like the same exact energy and
honestly I would have never thought
twice about the way that Wendy walked
down the stairs and like I feel like
Karen might have not even seen the way
she walked down the stairs just that she
was coming up but like the fact that she
caught that it was just so funny no it's
it's literally like Peak comedy like
it's hilarious um so I just can't wait
for part two and three and we're not
going to be podcasting but like just
know but after part three I feel like
we'll have a recap of everything so
we'll know where we're at and what's in
the binder are they going to take a
Christmas break maybe maybe okay um and
then real houses of Atlanta which I I'm
having like a hard time getting into the
groove of because it's such a shift like
Nini being gone like actually left like
a seismic is that the right word mhm it
depends what you going to say hole shift
hole sure like a Gap a side
a sizable like there's a energy shift
for sure um and it's just not being made
up for with like Marlo Latoya and Drew
even though that final conversation with
Drew and her husband was crazy I'm like
damn these people are really like
opening up on reality television yeah
and on the one hand I'm like it's kind
of annoying when a couple goes on TV to
fight or get divorced but I don't feel
like that's where they're headed I think
this is just their relationship and it's
just really interesting and honest got
so it was like it got super personal
and then by the end I was just like sad
yeah and the camera was like that was
just crazy yeah but I actually likeed
Drew I feel like Latoya was being really
like unnecessarily mean to her and Drew
is a full housewife Latoya I believe is
just a friend of and to me it's just
like so clear Latoya is like bending
over backwards to get on a full-time
cast member rotation yeah she's
obviously like on a trial period yeah
and it could go either way I think she's
really cute but she was just like giving
me such bad vibes like just like
annoying energy I feel that I also feel
like when there's like two new people
and then they start fighting but it's
like everyone else around them is like a
vet of it just felt like a season one
sort of motif it honestly felt like a
season one party like at um all the
girls are getting to know each other and
someone said telling about their
relationship that you can poke fun at oh
my god I've been getting like such crazy
nose blades and I lit is my nose
bleeding I heard you've been getting
crazy nose jobs I know um no but like
I'm like smelling blood in my nose but I
don't see anything no I'm just being
dramatic doesn't mean it's not there so
um yeah honestly what I find most
interesting about real houses of Atlanta
is their homes like I'm obsessed with
cia's house like B yeah and you know who
like actually for so many seasons in
Atlanta it was like this huge
conversation like everyone naming their
homes like who could build a nicer home
shat man yeah but it's like they all
used to come at each other being like
you have no money like and and everyone
came for Kenya when like her home
literally popped up out of nowhere she
built it in like a day and honestly it
really has stood the test of time it's
really very well done yeah but like
whatever happened to Chateau shereé I
don't know but I like how they all name
their homes yeah by the way Lake Bailey
is like so nice it's the place to be
yeah and uh Latoya being like it's a
river no and yeah and like her
insistence on River I'm like no it's a
lake like it's not that fun you're not
going to insult s the yeah um but to be
honest I felt like when they were all at
the um wine tasting party and Marlo got
up to get more wine with LaToya I feel
like she literally gave Latoya like the
best piece of advice and Latoya didn't
hear it no and I feel like Marlo really
summed up what it is about Kenya that
like makes her so toxic and it's so true
like she Cozy's up to you learns things
about you and then we'll use it I I
always have felt that she has some weird
information on Cynthia because Cynthia
is such a good friend to her for like no
reason and Cynthia's friendship with
Nene was like a huge problem like I just
I've always felt that like there's just
something off about Kenya and I can't
put my finger on it and in two seconds
Marlo completely uh Illustrated what it
is right but when she said it and from
what we got of Latoya's reaction I don't
think she heard her cuz she was like oh
so I shouldn't take advice from her no
that's not it at all no you should just
like have your guard up and just keep
something to yourself and I don't think
she got it even though I do feel what
you were saying last week there is like
a little shift in the way I feel about
Kenya I do think she's more um humbled
100% and she's like I think a lot of
people are confused about like why she's
like being so Carefree with LaToya but I
kind of understand that like when you
meet someone who just like changes your
Vibe like I don't think there's anything
weird about that I'm just so cautious of
of Kenya like she for sure she's just
she's not who she says she is like and I
really believe that okay no I I hear
what what you're saying and I also feel
like Latoya is in the exact same
situation that she's in like separated
and just like it's nice to have a friend
it's nice to have a friend yeah um so
honestly nothing has been really
happening I feel like there's this like
big blowup moment with just the
bachelorette party and I feel the St is
being set yeah um but I actually thought
it was like crazy seeing Riley uh
graduate from college and that's like a
thing with housewife um kids is like you
really can tell how long you've been
watching the show like I remember
singer in middle school you know what I
mean and I remember Riley when she was
so young and like reconnecting with her
dad like it's actually just like a true
Testament cuz like the housewives get so
much plastic surgery they all look the
same like since season 1 and it's just
crazy like when you see housewife kids
like all grown up especially ones that
like started filming when they were at
like an awkward age like that was Ali
Shapiro um Avery and Riley and now she's
like all grown up going to NYU and like
that's just crazy like for me like how
long I've been watching Housewives yeah
totally I loved she looked so cute at
her graduation like just such a cutie
also from the whole episode um oh yeah
but speaking of Avery um she posted on
her Instagram story that she applied to
go on The Bachelor Avery singer applied
to go on The Bachelor asre sent or maybe
Olivia asre sent it to me and then
someone else sent me that on Matt james'
season there's like a socialite on it
and she Cynthia rowley's daughter yeah
so now I just feel like what once was
like a really embarrassing thing to do
with a good payoff is now like becoming
like a cool thing to do like go on The
Bachelor like Cynthia rowy what what the
hell do you need to be going on The
Bachelorette for yeah no it's still not
to promote your always like a cool thing
to
do but I feel like there were some
people like a few select people who
would not see it that way like High
Society yeah and now like Society but
we'll see we'll get to know her Society
is calling Society is calling I think
Avery should go on The Bachelor I
actually think she's a good um Contender
yeah interesting well those are the
housewives Recaps that you definitely
needed to know you definitely needed to
know them and honestly I feel like a lot
of people who listen listen to our show
like maybe don't watch Housewives and
just like listen Recaps for fun and
sometimes people ask us like how would
there's so many Housewives like how
should I get started and to be honest a
really easy way to get started is
watching Salt Lake City because it's
season one and there's only a few
episodes but honestly so many people I
know have really picked up AIC during
quarantine because it has like the
fewest amount of seasons and I think
this is the end of the sixth season or
fifth I don't know fifth or sixth um and
it's just like easy and it's really I
was like re-evaluating everything last
night like as it stands right now I
would say pomac and Beverly Hills are my
top two New York is no longer a part of
it oh for sure no I picked up pic in
quarantine it was so much fun to watch
and if you're looking for a place to
start I would say that's an amazing
place pomac is definitely amongst my top
three I would have to think like
actually yeah probably pomac Beverly
Hills and we'll see about Dallas which
oh but Salt Lake City but it's too soon
to say that's the favorite yeah like you
have to have history in order to get to
the top three but I also love New Jersey
when it's on it depends on the season
yeah same with New York and same with OC
OC probably is my least favorite of all
time ever of all time bring back the
real house in Miami that's all I have to
say I just don't understand how real
house of Miami got canceled like what
was so bad about it that it like that it
got canceled and OC doesn't you know
yeah no 100% it doesn't make sense
because to me real hosters of Miami had
the perfect combination of like you know
thirst monsters real money Leah black
had real money Lisa HW had real money
thirst monsters like Adrien was that her
name who got married and like was 4
hours late to her own wedding
and then they did that oh thirst monster
then they did that um live reunion which
was [__] crazy they recorded the
whole thing live like it was really a
revolutionary franchise and it was just
like randomly canceled and nothing lar
was on it Lara was on it except the only
downfall was that woman Karen who was a
dentist and had her name wasn't Karen it
was Karent and I just never understood
why that was her name that's so funny
when I was going to text you last night
when we were talking about pic I was
about to be like when Karen was like
being everything I was about to be like
Karen why like just cuz like of Ken no I
know she was L she was literally like
the worst but then that girl Alexia
remember she was great and they all had
really nice houses I just don't know
like I just want an explanation I want
to see like the Q scores as to why that
was canceled and other franchises aren't
but like I understood why the real house
size of DC was canceled yes even though
it was excellent when the that couple
like showed up to the White House
Uninvited but was did the Bravo catch
that or they just like started filming
after that had happened and she happened
to be that person no Bravo caught it
remember they were like in the limo like
holding a fake invitation oh my God St I
think I I just saw a clip and Andy was
talking about it yeah no they literally
caught it on camera they pretended they
were invited to like some inauguration I
don't even know who was president back
then probably Obama right and they like
pretended they were invited and they
like couldn't get through the gates of
The West Wing like it was it that was
like a it sounds like a good show
because of that one moment but it wasn't
anything of the sort no I I didn't watch
it so I wouldn't know yeah um I just
remembered that if you're looking for
something to do over Christmas break
pomac and Salt Lake City are a great
place to start and that's our show
anything you want to say before you wrap
by the way every time I say before we
wrap up you know what I think of um
motor mouth mayel and hairspray it's
time to wrap this mother up should I
start saying that honestly yeah it is
time time to wrap this mother up no I
have nothing I have nothing to say just
we'll see you tomorrow everyone it's a
good day thank you so much for listening
to the morning toast the Millennium
Morning Show where we deliver the fast
stories that you need to know every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so if
you're watching us on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as podcast anywhere podcast can be found
so that's Spotify iTunes Stitcher public
radio ihart radio cast box all the
places so wherever you listen to podcast
find us the morning toast and leave a
five star review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are we hope you
have an amazing day we'll see you
tomorrow goodbye goodbye goodbye goodbye
goodbye
[Music]